[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar uncle mine reporter integrated
reporting for solid tumor and myeloid
somatic variants
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
david seidman scientific director
molecular diagnostics and serology
laboratories with centaura healthcare
laboratory services
dr seidman you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for the opportunity to
present to you today some of the work
that we conduct in our laboratory around
somatic variant reporting and analysis
and specifically today
i'm going to be talking about our usage
of oncoming reporter
software
and how we've utilized that in our
laboratory for
a standalone integrated reporting
mechanism
for some ngs profiles that we perform
before we begin
the presentation i do have some
disclosures here that are presented on
this slide
um just some standard uh ones
and with those
i will move on
so first i want to give a little bit of
background about who we are at uh
centerra
sentara healthcare we're a network of
hospitals that are spread throughout the
states of north carolina and virginia
predominantly located uh in the
southeastern region in the hampton roads
area but spread throughout the
entire state up to washington dc western
virginia
and the northeastern corner of north
carolina
we have over 200
physician offices that are associated
with us as a center medical group
we're in a private payer insurance
company as well
and our reference laboratory is located
in the flagship hospital pictured here
in norfolk virginia and this is where
our our hub is
for testing and where our molecular
laboratory
is
resides
within our laboratory our annual test
volumes over 9 million annual tests that
are conducted
in our integrated laboratory here in
norfolk
of this approximately 420 000 are
molecular based tests
and of those 420 000 approximately 1500
are molecular oncology based
for our molecular laboratory uh we're
spread across three uh independent uh
principles uh for testing that we
perform in the laboratory
molecular oncology genetics and
infectious disease infectious disease we
perform a variety of testing whether
it's viral
genotyping analysis
infectious disease diagnostics say for
herpes or respiratory pathogen panels
we perform a significant amount of cova
testing
and are currently looking into
other viral testing for
emerging
uh infections that are currently going
around
we also perform molecular genetics
panels
carrier screening panels for cystic
fibrosis fragile x spinal muscular
atrophy
perform factor five leiden and
prothrombin gene mutation analysis
but for today we're going to be focusing
on our molecular oncology work
particularly with our next generation
sequencing profiles for solid tumor and
myeloid analysis
but we do
offer some single gene testing
for solid tumor egfrk or sprafnras
and some myeloid heme
testing as well for jack 2 and bcr able
so
in our laboratory our molecular ngs
workflow
and particularly i'm going to focus on
our solid tumor workflow here
we perform about 700 solid team or next
generation sequencing profiles annually
so approximately half of all of the
oncology work that we're doing in our
laboratory is focused on this solid
tumor ngs profile
orders are
submitted to our laboratory by an
oncologist or through an in-house
pathologist driven reflex that we have
within our health care system
of this approximately 70 percent of the
cases that we receive
are part of this non-small cell lung
cancer reflex that is again pathologist
driven
and the goal of that reflex is to be
able to provide an ngs report within one
week of receipt of that
reflex case
and so
in our laboratory at least historically
these cases have been analyzed in a
week-long workflow
where we're able to
begin that process at the beginning of
the week and return the report by the
end of the week
historically
in our laboratory with workflows that
we've had we've identified
some bottlenecks within testing
so there's a lot of
touch points or or points within the
process of performing nest generation
sequencing that can impede that time
from sample to report
so with our prior workflow or what i'm
going to discuss as our current workflow
on this slide
we had a semi-automated sample
preparation system
we were preparing all of our ngs solid
tumor
libraries for sequencing manually
by hand and then our sequencing setup
was a semi-automated sequencing
that required a separate instrumentation
for
templating uh sequencing chip
and then that chip needed to be moved
over to the sequencer
post-sequencing data analysis was a
fairly
manual process
that we had employed
what we would envision as an ideal
workflow would be one where we can
automate that sample preparation
and automate the library and sequencing
as well as the data analysis with a
manual review on the back end for the
accuracy of those reports
so
smoothing out that process or
removing those impediments of sample to
report analysis
and allowing
more time
for our technologists to perform
any extra data review or
tasks that they may need to perform on a
daily basis
so
for ngs data analysis workflows
in our laboratory up until recently
data generated was analyzed across
multiple different platforms and
softwares
each one of these required the transfer
of data from one platform to another
and these can be significantly large
files when you're talking about the
sequencing output files so just the
single transfer
of
say a bam sequencing file from one
platform to another
can take a significant amount of time
and if you're talking about
uh caselid or for the week you know that
transfer could be a significant and slow
the
time to generating that final report
additionally when you're working across
multiple platforms each of those must be
vetted and verified for their accuracy
so going between each one verifying that
the data
transfer was appropriate that the
variants that were identified and one
are carrying over to another and that
the content is
correct
and so as mentioned from the beginning
of data analysis um in our laboratory
you know where that would begin with
base calling read alignment all the way
up to report generation
uh this data could have been transferred
up to three or more times just to get to
that final report
and so this has been
a bottleneck for us historically in our
laboratory is once we generate that data
how do we get that to the final report
and for a visual here
in our laboratory
previously we were using ion torrent
suite where we could perform primary
data analysis overall run quality metric
review
sequencing data analysis
and then transferring that large bam
file over to a secondary platform or
software ion reporter where we would
perform more in-depth analysis of the
variants that were identified
or mutations that we identified by ngs
and once we're able to perform that
secondary analysis and ion reporter we
are transferring a vcf file over to
a tertiary reporting software where we
were generating final reports for those
variants
and then finally we were downloading a
pdf
file that is printed and reviewed by a
medical pathologist or director for
accuracy and then that was transmitted
over to our limb system by physically
scanning that pdf report back into
the the system so
a lot of processes that require either
manual intervention by a technologist to
move a data file or to get that report
back out to the clinician
so now that we've talked a little bit
about the background of our laboratory
and testing
i'm going to talk to you today about our
updated
methodology or updated workflow for data
analysis and that's using the genexis
system and the automated
next generation sequencing workflow
to
perform that analysis
so
in the genexis system
um there's the opportunity to utilize an
automated extraction platform uh
pictured here on the left side of the
image the gpi genexis purification
instrument
this allows for automated sample
preparation
sample input
and then
nucleic acid extraction
output on the back end that's
quantitative and qualified
it can produce data files that can be
transmitted over to the genexis
sequencer pictured in the middle
containing all the sample information
that can then be programmed in for runs
on the genexis sequencer
this provides us with the opportunity to
automate our library preparation our
templating and sequencing on board of a
single platform
it requires very little hands-on time
the loading of
nucleic acid onboard the platform along
with
pre-packaged
reagents or
primers
and then it allows for just walk away
time
where the automation takes place for all
the preparation and depending on the
number of samples that are being run
that day
the whole process takes anywhere from 18
to 26 hours
so if you factor in sample preparation
and then sequencing
in as little as a day we can get results
back for uh sequencing results that we
can then
go over to reporting
and so on the final column and where
we'll focus today is our reporting
mechanism or data analysis mechanism
that we're conducting within the genexis
software or oncomine reporter
so
in the genexis software for data
analysis
when we are logging in or up to our
account or to our sequencer
uh we're able to review overall quality
metrics of the run um here in particular
we're looking at a full chip run uh each
chip has four lanes that are pictured
over here on the right in red
for those we can examine you know how
well our sequencing chip was loaded in
this case about 86.39 percent
uh we can look at our total reads
sequencing reads 47 million our accuracy
our final reads of the library to get an
overall
picture of how well this sequencing run
progressed and utilize these quality
metrics to determine
the likelihood of success of this run
additionally within the genexis software
for the assays that we have developed
here for our laboratory
we're able to check the qc status of
each one of these samples
prior to a technologist logging in to
actually review those so
within each pipeline we programmed in a
particular set of qc statistics that
allow our technologists to just simply
log in and see
red light green light almost
for quality control for that sample
so green check mark indicating that all
of our quality metrics have been met an
x indicating that there might be a
particular
quality metric within there that needs
additional review or requires repeat
analysis
when we click on that sample for review
we can see in this particular case that
our sample qc for rna has failed
particularly in this case read length
for that rna wasn't sufficient
i would indicate to our technologist
that this either requires additional
review
from the
data quality variant review perspective
or that we need to go back and
re-sequence this sample
but it's a real quick
mechanism for our team to be able to
understand which samples past all of our
overall sequencing quality
control metrics and which ones may need
that additional review or repeat
analysis without having to dig
deep to find that data
additionally within the genexis software
when we are reviewing those
each one of those samples
under the summary tab we are presented
with
say variants that could be applicable
for the type of sample that we're
performing
here on the overall summary tab we're
presented with uh variants that were
identified in this particular case which
is a combination of samples
here we're looking at a case that has
egfr t790m l858r variant egfr
amplification and then a met fusion
if we wanted to see more details about
these variants we can click on the
variants tab
located at the top and review our snips
our indels and our fusions our copy
number variants by clicking on each one
of the individual tabs
at the top of that variance section
so in this we can see again our t790m
l858r variant but we can also see more
details regarding this we can see the
actual nucleotide change we can see the
chromosomal coordinates as well as the
effective read depths or how deeply did
we sequence each one of these variants
and we can use this to provide more
confidence in the calls
that we are are generating
similarly we can click through the
additional tabs here we're looking at
the fusion in this case
and in this case we can see that the met
fusion that was identified as an exon 14
skipping variant
and we can see that we have sufficient
recounts for our our determination
within the laboratory to proceed and
review additional items here such as if
there's any additional breakpoints or
iso forms that may have been identified
but once we've gone through our basic
base data analysis our overall qc for
the sequencing chip our overall qc for
each sample and performed variant review
now we're ready to move into
reporting or how we would report these
variants within our laboratory
so with the workflow that we have
developed at centerra
in our laboratory
we've employed both the oncoming
reporter as a standalone version and the
akamine reporter
software as an extension
neither of these softwares come
pre-loaded on the genexis platform it's
the end user's choice to
download and utilize these softwares
the standalone
does go on board the genexis platform
and can be logged into by a separate ip
address
that's kind of partitioned from the main
genexis platform
and then the extension can be
downloaded directly into the gen x's
software and again
these are i guess
platforms that we have elected to
utilize
but first i'm going to
discuss our usage of the oncoming
reporter as a stand-alone
platformer software
so when we log into oncomin reporter
we're presented with the landing screen
where we can sign in and once we have
signed into akamine reporter we land on
the splash page where we're presented
with
a couple of options here
at the top um we can see that there
is a couple of icons that we can click
and drop down on whether it's analysis
settings account
under the settings heading there's a
couple of things that we can modulate or
modify that'll customize for our
laboratory
and so at centerra you know we have
taken say and made a custom report
template which i will display later
and that takes a little bit of time to
create within the software
but once you get comfortable with that
generation you can generate a report
template that's customizable for your
lab and your assay within about five to
ten minutes
you can also modulate filter presets for
how your you'd like your laboratory to
filter for clinical trials or therapies
you can program in your specific assay
that you're running in your laboratory
or what genes you're evaluating so if
you're running a dna panel you can
program in
what your dna panel is what specific
genes you're targeting
similarly if you're covering fusions rna
panel or copy number variants that can
be added there and customized to your
liking as well
additionally there are other options
there for cancer type findings biomarker
descriptions to your classifications
and signatory roles that can all be
modified by the end user
and we'll talk a little bit about the
signatory rules later
but once you've configured
oncomin reporter to the
likings of your laboratory
once you log in and you've got it
configured it's as simple as clicking on
create analysis to begin
generating reports
and once you click this icon here you're
brought to a page
that starts that analysis portion
you can select your vcf file
in this case we would still need to
download a vcf file and upload it into
the software
but once we've uploaded that vcf file we
give our analysis name we select our
filter preset that we
set for our laboratory and then we
select our assay and you can see again
it indicates the genes that were assayed
within the
particular vcf file that we're uploading
so these are all things that we can
modulate ourselves
once we've done that we're able to
upload and review content so the vcf
will be analyzed
and as long as it took for me to
transition that slide is how quickly
we're able to begin reviewing
the context of the variants that were
identified in that
vcf file
so here in this particular case we've
identified a kras g12c variant
we can see on the overall summary tab
that there are some biomarker based
relevant therapies that have been
assigned a number of clinical trials
allelic frequency prognosis significance
etc
there's relevant wild-type findings that
are currently grayed out but if we
wanted to we could elect to check those
boxes to include them on the final
report to place them in context
and then at the very bottom we can see
there's some additional information
whether that's
regarding say a therapy or trial that
might be contraindicated a breakthrough
or fast track file
overall on the summary page if there was
something that we wanted to say include
or exclude we have that option as a
laboratory
so say if we did not want k rash g12c to
show up on this report we could simply
uncheck that box next to the variant
additionally we can dig in a little
deeper
on each variant if we if we elect you
and select the details tab here
on this details tab
it will pull up a
more in-depth review of the particular
variants that we've identified so again
looking at krs
we can see the tiering classification
again at the top as 1a if we decided
that you know in this particular case
that the g12c was not a 1a variant we
could modify that
we can also exclude it from key variants
on our report if we still wanted to
include it we could demote that variant
by clicking on the exclude from key
variants icon and making a non-key
driver variant that would still show up
on the report but
not in the context of
being a key driver variant
additionally we are able to review in
more detail
each one of these calls so the tiering
criteria that met why was this
classified as a 1a variant we can review
the fda approved therapies that are
being presented to us as a laboratory so
here we can again see
two specific types of therapies that
have been
presented to us we have variant specific
therapies that are k-rash g-12c specific
or k-ras codon-12 mutation uh specific
and then also non-specific therapies
that are more uh at the gene level so
just kras mutation
and for each one of these we can elect
or
select to include them on our report or
exclude them so
say in the context of variance specific
therapy if we determine that
the contraindicated therapies
listed for chaos g12 and colorectal
cancer may not be applicable for a
non-small cell case
we as a laboratory can make the election
to exclude those from our report
similarly if we don't want to report
gene level
therapies we can deselect those as well
or therapies that we think may not be
relevant so we can see those are for
endometrial colorectal
we can expand each one of these icons or
subsections below nccn guideline esmo
clinical trials
and review the context and criteria
there for each one
and
similarly as we have described for the
fda approved therapies we can go through
as a laboratory modulate those ourselves
and make the final selection that we
feel comfortable with as a laboratory
for each one of these cases
once we've gone through our summary or
in-depth detail on a particular variant
the next step is to generate a report
and we click on the icon at the top
and once we get to the generate report
tab we will select our custom report so
we have a couple of centerra based
report templates that we utilize
and on that centeria report
some of the things that we've made
that we can do within the software is we
can add free text to those reports
so we can add our internal case
information a little bit more
information about the tumor such as the
pathological review of the
tumor content of the slide in a
percentage format
who our clients are physician ordering
pathologists and what our internal
container id information is and so we
can customize this report
and custom tailor it for each case that
we have so not only using the custom
overall report but when it comes down to
each individual sample we can tailor
that report at the individual sample
level as well
once we've completed this information
our report is ready to go and we just
click download report
and this is how it would come out on the
back end so this is an example of a
customized report that we have for the
non-small cell case we've been going
through our relevant findings for
non-small cell are presented here at the
top for genes that were assayed we see
the kras t12c being called out overall
and then not detected in the remaining
genes in that panel
we see our relevant biomarkers table
which gives a little bit more
information about that k rash d12c the
allelic frequency the variants that were
identified
any breakthrough or fast track
alerts that are below those are signaled
to
the end user of their report
and then on subsequent pages we do
provide more information about
the variant whether it's the specific
read depths or quality calls
information about trials or therapies as
well
on the final page or near final page of
the report we have our customized assay
that we're presenting the genes that we
tested for any disclosure statements
that we've
elected to include on the report methods
and limitations laboratory statement
and then finally we have a location
where a medical director or pathologist
can review and approve of this report
and so once this report has been
generated and printed printed
it can be signed out
and scanned back into our
lens system for
reporting
however
another feature of the standalone
oncomine reporter system is that once
this report has been generated and
reviewed
we have the opportunity to
place an electronic signature on that
report
so we can assign signatory roles within
the akamine reporter software
for
different levels whether it's a
technologist reviewing the case or it's
a say
pathologist who is reviewing and signing
that case
out
and so once we have gotten through the
process of
reviewing that we can create logins
based on signatory roles a sign report
icon will
populate and once we click on that it
will require a password
for the
individual who's signing that report
what role they're signing under here
we're displaying say a medical director
for center molecular diagnostics any
comments that they would like to add
and then they can just click sign report
and in the end
their electronic signature will display
in
the akka mine reporter software
you can see all the fields
that we had previously been able to edit
such as our template or case information
has now been grayed out and can't not be
modified so once this report has been
signed out it is
finalized and no additional edits can be
made unless the signature is removed and
then we can go back and make
modification but
once the electronic signature has been
applied
it we can download that report to review
it again
and we can see our
medical director's signature has been
electronically applied to that report
and we can go ahead and either print
this report out and scan it into our
limbs
or
another option that we've been able to
work through with the oncoming reporter
software is the ability to send this
report
so this icon here we've been able to
configure with our lim system to
transmit this report directly from
akamine reporter
into our lens
so it allows the electronic uh transfer
of that final report with the electronic
signature over and doesn't require any
download or printing or manual
signatures of that report
it also helps
ensure that the correct report is
going into the
correct location within the limb system
if you take into human factor
um
and seeing those reports get scanned
into the limbs uh there can always be a
chance of error of that report getting
scanned in under the incorrect specimen
this helps prevent that
potential error step or pitfall by
sending it directly back to the
container id that we have programmed
within our system
so this has been an overview of the
standalone akamine reporter so again
this is something that we've downloaded
and we utilize as a standalone
configuration within our laboratory
there's also the option for working
within the genexis software with
oncoming reporter extension
so here you can see under our setting
configuration we have an akamine
reporter selection
and again this is a software uh that we
have downloaded within the genexis
platform um it does not come pre-loaded
with akamine reporter it would be
something that would be the laboratory's
choice to download and employ this uh
within their within their lab for usage
but if we do click on this settings icon
and we do want to go into oncoming
reporter within the genexis software we
would just click on that icon there
and similar to the standalone
model we're presented kind of with a
splash page except this one is a little
bit
reduced and what you'll see is instead
of seeing the overall
screen where you're presented with an
opportunity to say create analysis
we're more looking at the settings of
the software here
so report templates again filter presets
biomarker descriptions
these are things that we can custom
tailor to ourselves
within the laboratory and you can see
that we've created a few separate report
templates for our own usage here center
report template overall
one where maybe we're only running a dna
based panel
report template
one where we might not be reporting copy
number variants due to
a quality metric that maybe wasn't met
or a low tumor percentage
but we're able to
manage those report templates and
customize them for our needs
whether it's on an overall basis or
sample based
analysis
and again once you've created your
report templates
you're ready to go with analysis within
the platform
so
within
again the software if we're looking at
our variance tab where we were
performing review earlier
in this case we're looking at
myeloid malignancy
where a mipple 515 variant was
identified
what we can see
once we have the oncoming reporter
software installed is that there's an
icon that we can click on that will
launch i oncomine reporter out of the
genexis software
clicking on this icon it'll pop up that
review tab
that we can see
[Music]
that we're looking at in a standalone
version earlier
we can review
criteria
again by clicking through these
different tabs summary details or
non-key variants that may have been
identified in this case
and we can again see the overall uh
summary review for tearing frequency or
any prognostic or diagnostic
significance
similarly within the
extension version we're able to go
through and review each one of these
calls at a more detailed level by
selecting that details tab
again we can expand to review the
tiering criteria that was met we can
review clinical trials in this case
there's no therapies that were
identified or approved
but we can again go through and perform
that review and determine if this meets
our needs and are we in agreement with
the call that is made here
and again we have the option to modulate
this as needed
one tab that i haven't gotten into just
yet is the non-key variance tab
and on this particular case here uh
we're looking again at a case where a
runks fusion was identified um similar
on the summary tab we see that is been
identified with the same similar
findings of other variants that we've
discussed earlier with the
biomarker-based therapies or prognostic
clinical trials etc
but in this case we did identify a
non-key driver variant and if we click
on this tab we can see that listed here
this b core
1694 tyrosine variant at a lower limit
frequency 6.1 percent
if we click on this tab and we see that
there's a variant here or we've
identified it previously
through our data analysis
we can perform a deeper review of this
variant and determine
is it applicable to the case that we're
profiling
is there anything of significance that
this might be worth
reporting out as a relevant finding on
the case
and if we determine
internally that this is a worthwhile
variant to include as a relevant variant
on the case we have the ability to
promote that so similar to how we can
demote a variant to a not to become a
non-key driver variant
which will still show up on the report
just to be clear the non-key driver
variants do show up on the report
in a section that is separate
but if we decided we wanted to promote
this we would just click the
actions button here and we can promote
that to
a key driver variant that will show up
at the top of the report so if we've
decided that this b core variant should
be
reported out
we have the ability to promote that and
include it on the report
similarly if it's something where we
feel
like maybe this b core variant isn't
really um significant we don't want it
on our report at all we don't want it in
the non-key driver variant section we
don't want it on the report at all
after we promote it we can deselect that
box and it'll will not show up on the
report at all so it really leaves it to
the end user to be able to make those
calls and
modifications to their final report
but if we were okay with this being the
report that was going to go out
the next thing we would do
is we would save that
and then we would click over onto the
reports tab in the genexis software so
we went through
a few of these different ones earlier
where we went through the qc the overall
summary the variance and now we're
looking at our reporting tab
in this reporting tab
if we click generate report
it'll pop up a screen that allows us to
select oncoming reporter report with the
software we've installed
it allows us to select our report
template highlighted there's our center
report template and when we do that our
customizable fields that we have elected
to include on our report pop-up
and we're able to complete these to
our needs
once we've done that
we click generate and we have our final
reports that we're able to download or
utilize for our needs so we have our npl
515 case on the left our runks fusion on
the right
similar to our solid tumor profile that
we displayed earlier relevant findings
shown at the top of the report
genes where we detected uh particular
variants uh genes that are relevant
where we did not detect anything
the findings from the relevant
biomarkers whether there's any trials or
therapies associated
prognostic significance and
even diagnostic significance if we're
including that on our report
but uh this would be the final report
that we generated
and this was all done within the gen x's
software so we didn't need to transfer a
data file anywhere you know once we've
downloaded the oncomin reporter software
into genexis
it becomes integrated into that workflow
where there's no transfer of large data
files like the bam file the vcf file is
self-contained within the platform and
we're able to get a report so
it really reduces that need to transmit
these files across multiple different
platforms just to get to this point
where we have a nice what we feel is a
nice clean report on the back end to
provide out
so in conclusion
the oncoming reporter software can be
provided as a stand-alone software that
is partitioned from the overall genexis
platform or integrated as a
kind of additional
widget or software within the
genexis platform
it allows for lab specific customizable
reports that are tailored to the needs
of
the assays and panels that we're
performing
the hands-on time which has been pretty
significant in the past is significantly
reduced with the genexis workflow
particularly with the data analysis i
think as mentioned with the integrated
workflow all of that data analysis can
be contained within one platform
from raw data analysis overall quality
metric variant review down to the report
generation
in stand-alone mode
even even with it being separate it only
requires the transfer of a vcf file and
at that point it's a filtered vcf file
so it's very small it's only the
variance that we are looking to report
again as mentioned the oncoming
extension can be installed by the end
user which requires no data transfer
the variant review and classification
within the platform we feel has been
significantly simplified
whether you're working in the extension
or the standalone
the report generation does not take a
significant amount of time it's only a
few clicks it doesn't require navigation
too a few different pages or a ton of
input
from the technologist to get to that
final report
and then a feature of the standalone
version is that electronic signatures
can be applied if a pathologist or
signatory role wanted to log in
electronically to provide that signature
they're able to
and we're able to transfer that data
directly electronically from our limb
system instead of needing to say print
these
reports sign them and then have them
scan back in so overall we find that the
workflow whether standalone or
integrated has presented us with a much
better smoother workflow
for our laboratory operation
and with that i'd like to conclude my
discussion of the
oncoming reporter software
and its usage within our laboratory at
santera and i'd be happy to
address any uh questions that you have
and again thank you for your time
thank you dr seidman for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started and our first
question is
how many variants do you typically have
to curate and how much time per report
is required when using
uncle mine reporter for variant review
and clinical curation
of tumor samples
that's a that's a great question and i
think my answer is it really depends
and a lot of that is on a variety of
factors
depending on the number of variants that
you identify within your panel you know
i would say for us we're using
smaller more targeted focused panels
typically identifying a handful of
well-known variants
so the time to review and report
doesn't typically take that long
if you expand the content of your panel
to a larger
maybe more
expanded panel or if you're identifying
variants that may not necessarily be as
well as classically known or defined
the length of time to review those can
be extended but that's really at the
discretion of the
end user and how in depth that they want
to go with each variant that is reviewed
or curated
so again you know just depends on the
content of the panel
that you are sequencing and reporting
and again you know
if you're identifying you know variants
of unknown significance tier three
variants or
any any other variant that might require
that additional
uh review it's really at the discretion
of the end user but for us you know if
we have a negative report it takes it's
very quick to generate that you know
from the time we upload the vcf about 30
seconds to the report
if we're identifying well-known variants
you know maybe a minute or two
five to ten minutes at the longest
all right thank you
next question
how long is a typical uncle mine
reporter report
again yes so another great question yeah
and again this uh also depends
um the report is completely modifiable
so
any section that we choose to include on
the report or exclude can either reduce
or add to the length of that report
for us you know a negative report would
be about a page or two
for
one with a variant that say has
assigned clinical trials or therapies
those can extend a little longer you
know anywhere from
3 to 11 pages and those are just for the
reports that we're generating
if you add additional sections in there
i think one of the sections that we
don't include on our report are gene
descriptions
on that report you know there's things
that will add to the length so if you're
looking for
a lengthier report you're able to make
that if you're looking for a short
compact report that can go out
you're able to achieve that as well but
overall um the reports that we're
generating out of our laboratory are are
relatively i would say relatively
compact
thank you
next question how often does uncle mind
reporter update content
um so for us at least what we're seeing
currently is that we're getting updates
on a monthly basis uh we're seeing those
come through for the
standalone and the integrated versions
of the
software
if configured within the
genexis system those updates can be
as simple as an automatic i don't say
automatic but you know clicking an icon
within the
software to update that content
when they do update the content they
provide all of the
updates and changes that uh have been
made there whether it's anything with
the
variant classification any additional um
guideline recommendations or therapies
trials
update to genes available
uh gene descriptions etc so it's a
pretty comprehensive
um
update packet
that is provided depending on the extent
of the update
but all that information is available
there it's typically on a monthly basis
right
thank you
next question is
can we use customized panels from third
parties or does it have to be through
thermo fisher
so from from my understanding for the
usage of oncoming reporter the vcf file
that is generated needs to come through
either the ion reporter platform or the
genexis platform
so whatever data that is being generated
in order to push that through oncoming
reporter
would have to be analyzed in either of
those platforms
thank you
next question
can someone with a basic knowledge of
bioinformatics
utilize this platform for data analysis
with ease
i would say so um you know i i think you
know within our laboratory
we have a
trained bioinformatician but for the
rest of us you know none of us have that
classical bioinformatics background
and
we found that as a team that we're
readily able to navigate these platforms
and software's
without needing to have that necessarily
in-depth background um
uh education but um it's it's a fairly
straightforward platform to to utilize
you
next question
can
um how does the uncle mine reporter get
access to what is to be analyzed
uh so for
for our needs within our laboratory
we're downloading uh
if we're talking about the standalone
version
we're downloading a filtered vcf file
from the genexis software from our data
analysis so that vcf file that's
generated
within the platform is then uploaded
into the software
if we're talking about the integrated
version it's utilizing the data that's
currently within the platform so when we
want to move forward or advance with a
report using that integrated mode
all the data that's needed
is pulled directly from the gen x's
platform so
sandalin
for us we're downloading a file and
uploading in the integrated mode it's
simply having that
making that choice or election to uh
install the oncoming reporter
software there and then once that's
enabled
navigating through the the software to
have that data
uh report generated
thank you and we will wrap up with that
question
do you have any final comments for our
audience
i know just thank you for for attending
today thank you for your time i really
appreciate it and hope i was able to
provide you with some
good information or details about a
pokemon
well reporter you again dr seidman for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you